[Musica]
ma che stai facendo
ti stanno disegnando i capelli poi però
sbagliato volevo cancellarli
se sì con un bastone disegni oggi vitale
in vena di scherzi ma che anche io mi
piacerebbe farli qualche scherzetto
vi ricordate l'ultima volta che abbiamo
provato gli scherzi di 123 go come è
andata e se non ve lo ricordate andate
poi a vedere il video dopo questo video
comunque ho in mente un po di scherzetti
da fare a vitale ora vi dico subito il
primo scherzetto che andrò a farle sarà
super divertente ma voi mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace su questo video
e se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila mi
piace allora fare una terza parte in cui
proviamo gli scherzetti di 123 godi
tronto modi dei five minutes kraft
insomma decidete voi quali scherzetti
volete che proviamo alla fine del video
scriveteci nei commenti quale lo
scherzetto che vi ha fatto più ridere di
tutti anche noi vi diremo il nostro
preferito se non mi seguite su instagram
andati a seguirmi nome anite stories
se volete seguitemi anche su tik tok e
se volete entrare a far parte della
storia
family cliccate sulla campanelline
8 e ora iniziamo subito con il primo
scherzo
[Musica]
berlino sei pronto per il primo scherzo
dei pronto a vederli senza denti e
diventerà il secondo me no però forse
vitali ok ho preso quello che mi serve
per questo primo scherzo
fondamentale la mela devo stare attento
a berlino perché merlino ad ora le mele
infatti lo chiamiamo anche superman ii
su super melino oppure berlin do poi un
pacco e district che in fisseremo nella
mela per fare finta che siano i denti
devo cercare di fare in modo che lui non
le guardi bene attentamente così e non
si renderà conto che in realtà non sono
i miei denti e book
iniziamo provò a infilzare l'eticità
nella mela spero di riuscirci e che ho
fatto ho fatto i due buchi nella mela
per inserire le tic tac e vediamo se si
stanno e combatto per radicova è troppo
divertente su brevi lo meno abbia due
denti e ora manca un'altra cosa
lo scoppio di carta la scozia di carta
serve a fare in modo che sembri che mi
manchino due dance infatti né spacco un
pezzetto
dopodichè lo colora di nero ecco fatto
ovviamente voi non fate questi scherzi a
casa e siamo noi che siamo pazzi e
facciamo questi scherzi assurdi come fa
a parlare
a new york evidenti
ora non c'è tempo da perdere per lido
che stai vedendo berlino sto cercando la
vela da mangiare per lire qua ora di
chiamare vitale video user ci cascarono
bocco loro con a scongelare le prove
il cane o qualcosa da mangiare
l'artista dopo vieni ti senti dono che
gli artisti alleli voglia di una mela
perché no sempre un momento di una mela
ok però prima gli do un morso io ok del
morso che pure mi forniva hanno visto
questi bianchi studenti voi che ho visto
in bocca e tuttosport sporche di
inchiostro c'è no è un pezzo di cartone
solo di nome questo scherzo è riuscito
un pochettino tanto
[Musica]
ok allora visto che la vita mi ha voluto
fare questo scherzetto
ho deciso di rispondere con un altro
scherzetto dei miei questo nello
specifico è una specie di trucchetto di
magia che ho visto dal canale 123 go è
una specie di levitazione dove sembra
che la persona sta volando e in realtà
c'è il trucchetto lo andiamo a fare
insieme abbiamo i dolci se il kit uno
scherzetto insieme a me facciamola
scherzetto dell'inter si chi allora per
questa scherza ci serve roma un bastone
poi ci serve è una scarpa perché
dovremmo mettere dentro è la coperta per
coprire tutto vado a prendere la coperta
intanto e andiamo a coprire con la
coperta questo bastone poi dobbiamo solo
infilare la scarna qui e fare questo
effetto di levitazione perderà un colpo
annita ieri
[Musica]
ieri intanto style evitando come una
torta berlino dimmi la verità c'è
qualcosa dietro qua vero ma c'è qualcosa
di strano in quella scarpa dove è
comparso ho capito troppo allora dovrei
resistere di più però è stato divertente
e un po confuso vicari amoroso farmi
questo scherzetto e allora tocca a me
fargli uno scherzetto a destra ma vi
avviso che sarà che cosa stai dicendo
e giunto il momento della mia vendetta
ho in mente un bellissimo scherzetto di
123 gol e spero che riesca ve lo faccio
vedere subito è questo qui
[Musica]
avete visto sembra super divertente
spero che funzionerà su vitale spero che
sei super divertente la sua relazione
allora iniziamo subito dato subito in
frigo prendere qualcosa da bere
guardate che cosa ho trovato vi prego
però ancora meglio dell'acqua perché
renzone in più anche le bollicine sarà
troppo divertente basta fare un tank io
qua dietro mi sembra proviamo assieme
speriamo di non sbagliare di nuovo le
vere l'aranciata super curioso e
vorrebbe per la mano al vino tu non puoi
perla dello zucchero ecco qua il buco lo
vedete non è troppo grande perché
altrimenti se ne accorgerebbe
ma è abbastanza grande per far uscire
una buona quantità di aranciata e ora
chi amiamo le vediamo come reagirà si
strucca vitale di elio qualcosa per te
si
ho deciso di farmi perdonare per tutti
gli spiriti ti ho comprato un'aranciata
buona l'aranciata ma non mi piace che
non ti piace non mi piace ma mi
piacciono tutte le cose con lo zucchero
era solo per vedere se era uno scherzo
oppure no dai media bene no come mai era
già abert perché l'ho avuto a saggiare
nel caso di non fonte più buona che e
aranciata
no infatti mi sembra strano che sia
aranciato appunto berlino ma che dice
guidare l'aranciata mi devo fidare
berlino si si io ti figlio tv dai bella
non ti preoccupare
[Applauso]
no male che ha avuto pochissima non ci
posso credere
che brutto scherzo grazie grazie e non
ti preoccupare 3 farò altri di scherzi o
se dovrà stare attenta la vendette di
l'italia è stato troppo divertente
[Musica]
allora per vendicarmi ho deciso che le
farò lo scherzo po schifo setto e cioè
mi chiamerò merlino lo farò sedere qui
sulla sedia e grazie all'aiuto di un
tortino al cioccolato è una specie di
ciambellina al cioccolato imposterò e
farò sembrare qualcosina di molto
schifoso che ha lasciato berlino sulla
sedia siete pronti vi mostra subito come
fare andiamo andiamo la tortina che noi
la tagliamo così e proviamo a fargli una
forma un po ambigua
proviamo anche uscire uno scherzo
perfetto merlino vieni merlino bisogno
del tuo aiuto per freschezza da vita
come togliamo seduta seduto chiedere a
rughe berlino si è seduto sulla sedia
ciò che produciamo salute tutti ciao
ragazzi
io non voglio dire che il trucchetto io
lo accetto sempre vero che lo
nascondiamo questi intanto perché mi
servirà anita viene a vedere carlino che
bravo che viene vedere qualche bravo il
nostro cagnolotto cosa stavate facendo
per gli stavamo facendo un po di cocco
l'italo accarezzavo è vero no marlino
ricordi 21 odore strano qua
che odore se hai mangiato qualcosa io
vedo niente sento odore di cibo berlino
c'è qualcosa di strano ora controlla in
giro non amo bravo c'è il momento di
agire che il debito del giro armati si
sono pronunciate qualche cosa da
mangiare qua no sinistra questo cassetto
forte giovane delle tante da mangiare ma
guarda che io non ho nascosto proprio
per niente
sento dolore di cose da mangiare berlino
che cos'hai combinato o no berlino la
droga sulla sedia
vediamo vediamo il punto vero affatto
ragazza quindi non guarda questi erano
gli scherzetti di 123 grossi abbiamo
provato qual è stato il tuo preferito
quello della l'abitazione è vero è stato
divertente che in quello però per me il
più divertente è quello della mela con i
denti il riso tantissimo e anche me mi
ha visto molto quello in cui mi facevi
finta che stavi lievitando come non fare
storie importo di zubair divertenti
quindi mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace fateci sapere qual è stato il
vostro scherzi preferita e ora vi
lasciamo qua quattro cartellini e su cui
cliccare cliccate su quella che
preferite
buona visione
[Musica]